vladimir tops y lleva 40 años al cargo
del zoo más antiguo de europa pero desde
el pasado 27 de febrero su zoológico ha
quedado atrapado en medio de la guerra
de ucrania más de 3000 personas
visitaban al año este zoo que ahora está
vacío los animales están estresados por
el sonido de las sirenas y explosiones
encerramos a los tigres por las noches
por si cae otro misil y si se abrirá la
jaula si podrían escapar vladimir nos
muestra dónde cayó el misil y ahora se
exhiben como piezas de museo junto con
animales disecados
has oído en las explosiones pueden ser
los nuestros o los rusos en cualquier
momento puede caer otro misil tenemos
mucha suerte de estar vivos pese al
peligro de que el zoológico vuelva a ser
atacado vladimir y su equipo no han
dejado de venir ni un solo día para
cuidar a los más de 4.000 animales que
sienten como su propia familia porque
trabajo con animales desde hace 20 años
es mi segunda casa en cualquier
situación da igual lo que pase estoy
aquí para cuidarlos y protegerlos nos
necesitan su chivo eso cruz
este zoológico de 120 años ha vivido y
sobrevivido la segunda guerra mundial e
incluso ha sido refugio seguro para las
tropas soviéticas cuando los nazis
invadieron ucrania hoy está bajo las
bombas diarias de las tropas rusas que
se encuentran a tan solo 30 kilómetros
de la ciudad de mico life